[Music]
okay I would like to thank the Academy
in its members and my fellow winners for
this amazing journey this moment will
stay forever with me thank you
as some of you have seen in my
documentary my grandmother is a tough
woman she might be called stubborn
how to reach but to me she's a real
world model making this documentary with
her I will discover about someone
courageous funny and caring she agreed
to open her safe not only to me but to
the world in a moment when the extreme
right is rising again in Europe and in
the US I encourage you to think about
who you are right now and think about
how everything you have experienced in
the past as for who you are now
my grandmother was traumatized separated
from her mother ashamed of her immigrant
roots scared of being Jewish she built a
new identity to fit in a society that
typically doesn't like people on the
margins she kept a secret from her loved
ones fought for her career as a woman
yes her story my story is also your
story be proud of who you are of where
you come from and do not let anyone take
that away from you and your family
[Applause]
I just want to tell her that you know I
love her I'm really proud of her and
relieved that today I know that deep
inside she's at peace with who she's I
would like to thank my parents who must
still be trying to figure out how to
stream this ceremony hi mom and dad
my friends my professors at NYU mascha
rock Justin Johnson a reverse lesson and
most importantly the man without whom
none of this would have been possible
the love of my life John Freeman thank
you